if you're struggling to decide whether
you should stay in school go get a job
or start your own business I'm gonna
help answer that question for you today
on this video hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs and I
recently got a question from one of my
subscribers love you guys
Paul who wrote in the say hi I'm Paul
right now I have faced some problems
that myself couldn't solve can you
please help me solve it my problem is
that I'm very unclear and vague at the
future I do not know if I should focus
myself on school now to try getting into
Stanford or go get a job
lease an office and work with my
classmates I'm obsessed with starting
the business but did not know how to
take the first step right can you please
help me give me a clear path of which
direction I should really take please
help me with this step thank you
commit Paul Paul is a fantastic question
and one I want you to know you're not
alone everybody goes through this
multiple times in their life you are not
the only one in the world going through
this right now with all big decisions my
advice always is to follow your heart
and not your head follow what feels
right
follow your passion even if it doesn't
make any sense at all because that's
gonna be the path that will lead you to
success and a happier life see a lot of
people tell you to do the safe thing do
the smart thing most people will go to
school and then get a job and then stay
in that career forever and ever and ever
and they end up hating their life as
years go on you start hating what you're
doing more and more and more and you're
living for the evenings and weekends and
the scary thing is that's most people
that is most people in the world most
people are not living their dreams
because they did the safe thing and they
listened to their head the logical thing
to do instead of the heart which was the
passionate thing to do and the scary
thing is quite often the people that you
take advice from the people who are
asking help from are those very same
people who were too afraid to ever risk
anything and bet on themselves they took
that safe path and so what's their
advice gonna be to take the same path
for you as well where if you look at the
top people in any field on
burners artists exactly if you look at
the top people in any field then people
were at the top of the top their passion
about what they did they are passionate
about continually about what they're
doing and they're exploring new things
even if it doesn't make any logical
sense because they're listening to their
heart and not their head so I can't tell
you what to do I can't tell you go to
Stanford I can't tell you start a job I
can't tell you go and start this
entrepreneurial venture from your email
from the question it sounds like when
you said I'm obsessed with starting the
business you want to follow that
obsession right that's where I'm
thinking you should be but it's gotta be
coming from your heart if you love
Stanford nuts bring your dream that's
where you want to go to go to Stanford
not everybody is supposed to be an
entrepreneur but if you love being an
entrepreneur that's what you want to
learn about even if there's nobody in
your families but an entrepreneur even
if you have no resources or connections
or ideas yet you will learn when you are
excited about something that's when you
really learn and pick it up and I don't
want you to live in regret I don't want
you to look back on your life when
you're 70 80 90 years old and you did
the same thing and you say to yourself I
really wish when I was 20 years old or
however old you are that I bet on myself
I really wish that I had taken that
chance because now you've lived that
entire life and you always are gonna be
wondering what if I want to share a bit
of a personal story to help bring this
home my sister works for the United
Nations and she had an opportunity to go
to a really dangerous part of the world
and my parents were telling me hey Evan
you know she listens to you tell her not
to go this is really silly it's stupid
she could get killed it's really
dangerous there if she shouldn't go and
I get that as parents you know myself
being a father you are always worried
about your children and as a brother
I want my sister to be safe you know I
want her to do things where she doesn't
have a risk of dying right I don't face
that risk in my profession but she
doesn't hers and when she asked me for
advice
I had to shut off all my brotherly
instincts I had to shut off the desire
for her to be safe to desire for her to
you know not get killed the desire for
me to want to see her every Christmas
because I don't want her to have to live
in regret I don't want her to live the
rest of her life wondering what F and so
I told her the same thing that I'm
telling you guys big decisions you make
with the heart and not the head I told
her to trust her gut I told her to
follow her passion and do what she felt
was right now she ended up not taking
that job and I'm so so so so relieved
but she did it for her she did it for
the right reasons not because other
people told her to do it
and so that's the key whether you're
thinking about school job starting the
business or any other big decision in
your life always listen to your heart
not your head and don't listen to other
people who are too afraid to chase their
dreams and take their advice and live
their version of your life instead of
your version of your own life believe so
those are you watching I'd love to hear
your thoughts on how you decided to
start your business or how you decided
to go from taking on a school or taking
on a job or taking on a company leave it
in the comments below I'm looking
forward to getting involved in that
discussion and if you liked this video
and you want to see more don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and the
newsletter thank you so much for
watching I'll see you soon